where do you see yourself in five years
ever heard of this interview question
i'm sure you must have this is one of
the most frequently asked questions
so what does the interviewer keep in
mind while asking you this
what is your safe answer the answer to
this can get quite delicate and can set
you apart from the other candidates
here we are to help you answer this
question smoothly
so today we bring you the interesting
video on how to answer
where do you see yourself in five years
before answering this question you need
to understand what the interviewer wants
to know while asking you such a question
when you are asked where you see
yourself in five years it is nothing but
a question about your career goals
employers want to learn about your goals
and see if it fits with a job they're
offering
interviewers wish to know if this job
role will satisfy you
and that you'll work hard and stay with
the company for a long time
they want to assess you on your vision
ambitions and career outlook they wish
to see if you have realistic
expectations of your career
and if this particular position aligns
with your goals overall
you must think about how this job aligns
with your broader professional goals
most jobs need training no employer
would be interested in investing their
time and money in a candidate who is
planning to leave
hence companies hire good prospects for
their businesses
those who are genuinely enthusiastic
about the job and those who are truly
dependable you should give an honest
answer this question
but make sure to present your answer
well in a way that can help you get
hired
you must make sure to think about your
goals before formulating an
answer to the interview think of this
question as an opportunity for you to do
a bit of career planning
and answer the question by developing
your answer to this question you can get
an insight into your career direction
however a wrong answer to this question
can wreck an
opportunity for you so how to answer
this question rightly
here are a few magic tips to help you
first and foremost do not answer this
question with an
i don't know and avoid joking this shows
you that you have
no seriousness towards this job in your
career employers want to see if this job
truly matters to you or not
it shouldn't look like this job is just
a way to pass your time or an
opportunity to break your unemployment
secondly when entering it is best if you
stay grounded and not bring up
unrealistic expectations
for example do not say things like you
see yourself as a ceo or a cmo in the
next five years
that will give the employer a feeling
that you are over
ambitious and that you may not be happy
if the growth doesn't
escalate to that speed very few
employers will be interested in hiring
you then
such an answer will also make your
current job just a stepping stone and
not something you truly want
hence refrain from speaking about
promotions or seeing your job roles and
rather stay
grounded finally what are you supposed
to say then
how are you supposed to answer the
question one quick tip is that you must
present your answers as
actions and not goals when answering
this question it is advised that you
break this question into parts
one as a short-term goal and another as
a long-term goal
this will help you channelize your
answer and provide good clarity to the
interviewer
for example you can say something on
these grounds for the next couple years
i would like to immerse myself in this
job and improve my skills around it
after which i would like to take up
additional responsibilities and help
others in the organization with my
expertise
when you say this it shows how solely
focused you are on this role
how excited you are to learn new skills
and at the same time
it also shows that your learning will
help the company in the future
make sure to mention a set of actions
you will undertake to help facilitate
your growth and not the final goal by
itself
the bottom line an employer wants to see
your future goals and see if it will
align with the company's needs
by doing so they will understand if you
are an asset to the company or not
preparing for this question is a great
exercise in understanding what you like
doing and what is genuinely meaningful
to you in the future
take the time to think about what you
want in life and present your answer
well
this way there are more chances for you
to be hired and you will also be happy
about where you will be in the next
5 years so that brings us to the end of
this video and i hope these tips are
helpful to all you job seekers out there
and i wish you all the very best thank
you for watching this video
and stay tuned for more from simply
learn
[Music]